you're
[Music]
you know to be here be voted by the fans
once again to be a part of all this all
weekend it's gonna be a great weekend
and for us to be able to honor Kobe
Bryant and his legacy and you know it's
just a it's a beautiful time you know
it's a beautiful time you know even if
even in loss it's a beautiful time so
just happy to be a part of as weekend
[Applause]
I don't believe impression you know if
you you're working your craft and you
you dedicate yourself to you to your
craft then you know you know you
whatever happens happens so I'm not I
want to believe in pressure much while
you draw
[Music]
I just think it's always important just
to give back to the youth you guys are
our future
you guys have beautiful minds spirit
energy is always high and you know I was
a young kid growing up in the inner city
but not much not much resources not much
help so for me to be able to be in a
position I am today to be able to give
back you know to not only to my hometown
but go across all over the world and
inspire people and inspire kids inspire
to youth I think it's just as important
as what I do on the basketball floor
[Music]
I mean I always appreciate it I mean
it's the game that I love is the game
that I fell in love with when I was a
little boy so for me to be a part of
office all weekend you know here with
you know all the all the fans all around
the world that we have that support our
beautiful game I never take this model
for granted
I already respect the frame just from a
competitive standpoint and building an
opposite ban when I was in Miami
competing versus Indiana Pacers teams so
you saw how they were always prepared it
was dedicated to their game plan they
were always ready for our matchups every
time we played them the battles that we
had versus those teams yet Indiana so
they need to have a level respect
because it was already there from the
jump
[Applause]
not only everywhere I mean not only
Mexico but all my fans everywhere not so
close please my fans all over the world
I just try to give back to anybody
continue to inspire them and you know
like I said I'm happy to be here
[Music]
[Music]
so again
well by the Commissioner allowing to
actual week to happen you know you know
with that change it definitely has
helped out a lot not only for the guys
that it's not a part of also our weekend
but for the guys that are partners so I
just tried I try to find at least a
couple days to kind of decompress and
get away from the game obviously you
know when you come to all-star weekend
basketball is gonna be the main thing
and amazing all this what you hear is
what you see every day and we dedicate
to this weekend for not only for
ourselves and our family but for the
fans so after I don't know I'll try to
find a couple days after the after also
after Sunday they kind of just kind of
get away from the game trying to fresh
them back up and get ready for the you
know the last you know running a regular
season
[Music]
Oh
I mean we know that he's watching over
us and you know it's our responsibility
to just represent the purple and go not
only for him but for all the greats
everybody has never come to the lake
show so I don't want to I really don't
want to sit up here and talk about it
too much you know it was very very
sensitive subject but he's with these
with us every day
just embrace it if you have his family
with them let them enjoy it let them go
around and see pretty much everything
you know it's not always it's not
promised that you'll be here next year
but the way he's playing he'd probably
hear a lot I think
but I mean you embrace it because you
know like I said I'm a guy who always
kind of live in the moment I don't think
about tomorrow because it's not promised
and only I can worry about it today and
how much I can make up an impact and
today and so you know embrace it have
fun it's a great weekend it's a lot of
things to do not only for yourself but
also for your family and enjoy
especially
now he was back win it when he came back
the first after the first retirement oh
it was a very joyous moment for for my
community for myself for my friends just
having the greatest basketball player
ever
you know something back playing the game
you know needed that inspiration growing
up in the inner city you know it's like
I kind of like lost lost the superhero
when he retired someone that I kind of
needed to help me you know someway
somehow even though he didn't know it
and I'm along with some other athletes
and and and people but it was incredible
it was so exciting when he said he came
when he was coming back and you know
obviously you know the basketball world
and everybody else that loved him and
loved the sport was a ecstatic about it
as well
[Music]
no I literally just got here I literally
just got off the plane he showed up a
see y'all I don't know I have no idea
what my schedule is today just a couple
of things on I don't know
I'm here from I'm here which for you
guys right now and I don't know if I'm
gonna doing anything else today as it is
but I have no idea
it's huh I don't know I mean how can you
be a bad Jim when you pick in 24 the
best players in the world
[Music]
you know being part of Team USA has
always been fun I mean it's always like
you know just to represent the United
States of America that red white and
blue is such a such a pride thing so you
know obviously with my name being one of
the you know you know names in the list
of players that just came out not too
long ago you know just honor even to be
mentioned to be mentioned you know so we
would see what happens obviously I got a
long season and hopefully still left
with the lake show so we'll tackle that
um you know after the season